hello and welcome to your eighth WX
Python tutorial this is Tori we're gonna
be talking about how to add a little bit
more flavor to your windows and in this
tutorial we're going to be most
specifically talking about how to give
buttons a bitmap image this way it just
looks more appealing maybe although I
will just add that my buttons aren't
exactly the most appealing buttons ever
but regardless that's what we're going
to do so before this video I made a
quick
sadface PNG image which we're going to
use for the exit so when the user goes
to file and exit like right now we run
this program and the window here you
know you're awesome text this is cool
but you know the users like I've got
other stuff to do file and then exit
it's just so easy they just hit exit and
they're done so what we want to add is a
little something-something there to
maybe convince them may want you to stay
a little bit longer so let's hop into it
the first thing I want to do is
rearrange a few things again most
notably let's bump this down because
we're going to be changing this and also
I would just like to change this as well
to do if you're going to edit the button
in any way it's usually easier to do it
this way and so just follow with me edit
item now we're going to change this to
just be W X dot menu item so we're just
giving it the WX pythons mode being a
menu item already and then what we're
going to do is define it a little bit
and first you say where it's going to go
and it's going to go under the file
button then we give it its ID and in
this case it's just going to be the ID
exit so it's going to have the exit
parameters that WX Python presets and
then finally it's got the
you know whatever you want it to say so
in this case it's going to say quit now
the next thing you want to do is you'll
want to give it its image so in this
case you'll do exit item or whatever
you've named yours set bitmap and then
in parenthesis here the only parameter
is the location so we're gonna say WX
bitmap and then in parenthesis you give
the location of this if it's in the same
directory then you just straight up put
the filename if it's not in the same
directory then you'll have to give you
know the full path C colon slash bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla
slash okay but in my case it's in the
directory generally if you ship out
anything or you install something on
someone's computer it's going to be in
the same directory anyway but if not
give the whole path hmm so next now that
we've done that the only thing we need
to do is do file button and we're going
to append this exit button or exit item
to the button so exit item or a pin item
exit ion and that should be it hopefully
we have a typo door screwed anything
else up so let's save it run it see what
happens and so here is our window and we
go to file and now they got a sad face
when they go to quit now something
you'll notice with a lot of windows like
if we look here at this Python window
new window is ctrl n open is control Oh
and then obviously like exit is ctrl Q
now when we come to our window you can't
see me but here I'll hit ctrl Q
nothing's happening if you can hear I'm
getting like oh the Windows notification
that whatever I'm trying to do isn't
working so ctrl Q doesn't really work
for me here but what you can do to set
ctrl Q to work is those are pretty nifty
you literally just type it in like you
do ctrl + Q and I did
a little tab before so this backslash t
means tab and then i said i just
strictly just said control q nothing
else we'll run it and i just suggest you
run this alongside of you so you can
just and said or you just take my word
for it and then now when you go here and
you look at the button it says control Q
there but even if you're not even using
it and then you hit ctrl Q it'll close
and you might be thinking well that's
probably just because it like recognizes
everything and so if you just have any
parameter there maybe it does it but you
can change it like you can say ctrl P
which normally corresponds to print play
in our case if we do this we'll run it
and here's our window again and it says
ctrl P there I'm going to just again you
can do this yourself or take my word for
it ctrl Q is not doing anything what if
I do ctrl P
sure enough it closes finally you can
also just not have a parameter in there
at all for like how to close it and
instead you could be like don't
and then backslash to escape the single
quote there and so don't and then don't
do it like that right so we'll put that
in there we'll save that we'll run it
and here's our window and now when they
go like this it says don't do it right
by the quit but if so now if I do ctrl Q
still nothing ctrl P still nothing so
you can really put anything you want in
there but if you do say ctrl a P or ctrl
Q or whatever it'll also act like short
keys and like that's just kind of coded
into W X Python again one of those
things that takes a lot of coding for
them to just you know be like okay if
they happen to put control in here so
anyway really cool stuff okay so anyway
that's it we'll quit the program there
and so that's the basics to adding
little icons by like menu items and now
what we're going to be talking about
briefly is a toolbar and in case you
haven't guessed it you can also add
little images for the toolbar
so stay tuned for the next video and
toolbars and as always thank you for
watching and subscribing